[Music]
so we are here live with Jackie Edwards
and Jackie is an author she is a rent to
rent expert and Jackie why don't you
just tell us a little bit about yourself
in your background
awesome so yeah I'm Jackie Edwards I and
originally from the US I've been over
here in the UK for a while now I started
off as an accountants and but really
didn't like accounting very much so I
spent quite a few years actually looking
for something else before I finally
stumbled on property based over in
Oxford now which I absolutely love and
and yeah so My partner and I got into
property and we're kind of looking for a
way basically to get cash flow so my
main goal was to be able to leave my
accounting job which I absolutely didn't
like and to be able to just have
something that gave me a more flexible
life where I could be able to travel and
just enjoy myself a little bit more and
you always read all of those books that
talk about how property is really great
for building wealth and doing all those
kind of things so yeah I did I did some
more research started going to local
property networking meetings and yeah
kind of stumbled into it and just jumped
in and said all right here's what we're
gonna do
I left my accounting job and said I'm
giving myself 12 months to build myself
a property business and decided on the
the rent to rent strategy ultimately
I'll go into the loads of detail about
why I set up that strategy and but yeah
decided on rent to rent and was able to
build a business and create my financial
freedom that way as excellent I mean one
of the reasons I asked you into the show
and thanks so much for coming out it's
because I get asked all the time about
rent to rents and I mean all I've built
up you know I quite a good portfolio and
some of that is ready to rent but you're
the master at rent to rent so I know you
said you didn't want to spend a lot of
time going to it but why rent to rent I
mean what was it that attracted you
about that for us the biggest thing was
cash flow we were really I mean my main
goal was to be able to leave my
accounting job and I needed to have the
cash flow to replace my income so we
looked at the strategies that gave us
cash flow and I started kind of before
service combination with a super cool
so focus we were looking at HMOs HMOs
and Oxford are quite expensive so we
could have maybe bought one we didn't
needed a hundred thousand pound deposit
when when we got started I also had no
credibility I'd never done property
before so we were trying to you know
raise funding get joint venture partners
even getting a mortgage we weren't able
to because we just had no experience we
didn't own our own property so there was
no real way to raise any funding so then
we said all right well what strategies
can we use that we don't need all of
that extra funding and to go through all
those loops and that was just rent to
rent so we decided that we would start
off with a rent to rent business the
goal was to get to about a hundred
thousand pounds of income within the
first 12 months and that would kind of
replace all of my income give us that
flexibility and then move on to buying
properties because I think the real
wealth from properties is from from
owning them in the long term and getting
the capital appreciation so I think you
need to have a mix in your portfolio so
phase one was the rent to rents phase
two is to start buying HMOs and then
phase three would be to do you know
whatever flips and start getting bigger
capital chunks amazing and to kind of
cut to the chase you said your goal was
to hit a hundred thousand pounds which
is a pretty good goal one hundred
thousand pound is a good salary yeah and
to do that from scratch when you don't
know anything about property in twelve
months I mean did you achieve it yeah we
did it was it was it was very very busy
twelve bat Wow it took a couple of
months to kind of get everything up and
running and to build up the momentum
with the marketing thousand pound profit
in twelve months how many how many
rental properties was that so we signed
ten contracts great yeah and question
how did you find those deals not knowing
anything about property just I mean so
did you go on any training courses yep
so we did some training a really big
believer in just making sure you're
educated and knowing what you're doing
before you get started I mean I went to
university to be an accountant I learned
that did you have loads of money to
start with we had some so we not loads
because I had to live on that for the
next 12 months because I'm with my job
if you don't know me at all
we had enough for a training course so
we did we did a 12-month mastermind
program and so that's what I had and
then once we started is where we learned
how to kind of raise more funds so we
were able to use my partner's pension as
our investing funds to get started so we
set up a SAS pension and were able to
loan half of the money into our property
business so I'm trying to think it was
probably it was it was about a hundred
thousand pounds to get started in the
very beginning would you say to somebody
because people will always find reasons
why something won't work for them you
know oh it's different for you I mean
you didn't have any experience in
property you had to be creative and use
pension to get some money together what
would you say to someone that says I
haven't got any money at all could I
start a rent to rent portfolio is it
possible it is anything is possible I
think if you haven't got any money it's
all about building up your relationships
and really kind of building building the
team around you and other people that
have money cuz you're gonna need your
joint venture partners or or you know
your other kind of partners in the
business and and it's all about kind of
getting out there and meeting as many
people as possible to build those
relationships so that you can to raise
some funds because you do need some
money for any kind of property investing
just just I mean you're running a
business you need your business set up
costs and you just need to have that
little bit of a cash buffer in case
something goes wrong so no matter what
you need some funds and if you haven't
gotten any of your own then working with
other people is a great way to do it cuz
there's so many people interested in
property investing and if you know
you've got the time and they've got the
money but no time it's a perfect
partnership absolutely and and you you
do need money but it doesn't have to be
your money yeah you can you can leverage
other people's money time knowledge
excellent so what advice would you give
them to someone because like I guess if
someone had a lot of money they probably
would not be super inclined to rent to
rent necessarily but if they haven't got
a lot of money if they've got nothing or
15 grand or or whatever then there might
be more drawn to it so the people are
watching this are probably still
watching because they're thinking rent
to rent very little or no money down
Dale's 100 grand a year cash flow I'm in
what advice would you give to those guys
just that they're beginning
yeah other than getting educated yeah I
would say yeah it's once it's taking
action and just getting out there and
doing lots and lots and lots and lots
and lots of viewings because a lot of
people come to me and they say oh rent
to rent doesn't work in my area and my
first question is well how many
properties have you gone out to see and
they're like oh I've I've been see three
and I'm like look that's that's just not
enough it's it's never gonna work you
have to just be out there and looking at
lots of properties in the beginning
you're gonna sound like an idiot I
sounded like an idiot no idea what I was
talking about never done this before I
was talking to landlords and of course
they told me no because I sounded like a
crazy person but the the more you do it
and the more practice you get and the
more times you explain it and look at
them and say oh that didn't make sense
I'll change it a little bit next time
I'll change it a little bit next time
and you get more confident and then it
just gets easier and easier and easier
but you have to go through the work in
the beginning of building it up figuring
out what you're saying and how did it
how to explain it so where would you
start you save you lots of houses where
would you find those houses to view in
the beginning just go out with agents
and just look at the properties there so
you've decided you wanna do rent amount
you've read your fantastic book which by
the way if you're watching this and you
haven't read Jackie Edwards but you need
to read it on Amazon little plug for you
know it is great you've read the book
you're excited you want to do rent to
rent you've got a little amount of money
on or nan you go on Rightmove you start
looking for properties that what maybe
there potentially lend themself to be a
HMO perhaps yeah so yeah if you haven't
got loads of money going to agents as
probably the quickest way to get started
because everything else you need a
little bit of advertising funds so going
to the agents is a perfect way to get
started and it's it's just looking at
properties that could potentially be an
HMO or maybe even properties that are
already HMOs and maybe they're just not
in the greatest condition or they're not
maximizing the rent that they can get
and it's finding maybe three bed
properties that have two reception rooms
that you could turn those into bedrooms
so it's looking for where you can add
value to a property or where you can add
value to kind of that owner that
landlords life and then just setting up
the viewing with the agent and and again
you have to practice talking to them
you're not going to know exactly what to
say the very first time you speak with
them but the more you do it and
especially with agents the more
properties you see the more you get to
understand your local area as well and
see what types of properties there are
what kind of prices there are and what
different ranges and different
conditions so in the first few months
for me it's just a lot of learning and
just getting used to everything and
building up that momentum really so you
might not get any deals for like that
first month maybe that first two months
but you'll have learned so much and then
you'll have the confidence you'll
understand your area understand the
prices and you'll you'll kind of keep
going from there absolutely that's
brilliant advice just do it get out
there and view the houses and these the
houses that you're going to be looking
at presumably they're housed up for rent
not for sale
and then you're gonna say to the agent
so my my normal kind of story or my
business pitch because I I feel like
rent rent is a proper property business
and so I tell them my business is I'm a
relocation agent I work with companies
in the local area to help house their
employees so that's what my business is
to them because that way with an agent
you know I'm not competing with them I'm
not saying oh I'm another local landlord
I've got loads of spare tenants you know
I want to put them in this house agents
kind of like I work with landlords and
tenants what are you doing so my
suggestion is kind of having that
specific business of what are you doing
that's not the same as the agent but
it's a proper business that you can
explain to somebody and yeah builds it
up from there that's excellent I mean I
must I must say I do admire the fact
that you you managed to build that kind
of rapport with agents when they were
giving you properties or I've personally
found it very difficult dealing with
agents because they just don't get it
and they are threatened and they don't
understand and when you confuse them you
lose them so my rents our rents I've
usually found them direct to landlord so
I mean what advice would you give about
rapport building with agents I mean most
of mine have been direct to landlord as
well so just a couple with agents and it
it just takes time and in building up
that trust with them it doesn't happen
overnight I'd say start with the smaller
agencies because they don't have as many
hoops to jump through the bigger ones
have you know their legal department and
the processes that they have to
the contracts they have to use and they
can't step outside of that and they're
just not interested the smaller ones if
you can talk to kind of that
owner-director operator person and and
build that relationship so that they can
see what's in it for them as well
because you're more of joint venturing
with them than just kind of be using
them as a source or almost so they can
see that they can make some money it
makes their life easier as soon as
they've got a property they can just
pass it to you they make their
commission everybody's happy but it just
takes time to build up that relationship
but once you've got it then you've got
that sourcing partner that can just keep
bringing properties your way that's
really where you want where you want to
be where is the best or what's the best
way to find landlords direct yeah so for
me the thing that worked the best for me
was getting the list of licensed HMOs
from the council and just sending them
letters because I mean that was my
target I wanted to have HMOs especially
in my area and it's growing more now
with the additional licensing
requirements and the additional planning
and article four issues so starting with
a property that was already in HMO it
had everything it already needed at the
license the planning permission the fire
safety stuff and the owners were open to
HMOs they already kind of knew what was
going on so it was targeting them
finding the ones that were really
struggling didn't know how to properly
manage the property or had some other
problem and just being able to help
solve it that's excellent fantastic so
when did you start out doing this so
it's been just about four years yes what
does what does your strategy consists of
now do you still do regiments um we do
we don't do loads of advertising so most
of ours come through word-of-mouth now
or properties our landlords have more
properties and they pass them on to us
so I've got a small team that manages
the rent to rent portfolio so we're
pretty happy with how that's going and
don't do those of advertising we've
bought a couple of our own properties as
well now so we own a few in Oxford and
and in some of the surrounding areas and
recently our newest strategy is we've
just bought 27 acres of land where we
are going to start a farm so we're not
gonna do a big development on it we're
going to have our own alpaca farm so
that was kind of one of our dreams oh we
first oh yes right yeah but that's the
thing property is a vehicle and being
able to have of your own bread to rent
portfolio you've bought a couple of
houses and
investments now you can start to do that
kind of thing exactly exactly and we've
got kind of the connections we need
because it's basically just a proper
blank field so we're thinking of doing a
bit of container storage on there so I'm
gonna meet with a few people that do
that strategy that I've met through the
different property networks and we might
do some glamping pods and stuff but I've
got I know the people to kind of help us
with that now so it's awesome so what
would you say your average week looks
like now ah so there it's it's
relatively relaxed I probably spend
about 10 hours a week working on my
property business so on the managing the
actual properties because I've got a
team that does it so most of it is you
know meeting with them making sure
they're on track and that they don't
have any huge questions the rest of the
time I do coaching and mentoring so
about quite a few online programs and
working with kind of private clients and
then it's just relaxing and setting up
the farm is basically with yes I heard a
quote and it said if you do in the early
days what most people aren't prepared to
then you'll be able to do in the later
days what most people can't do exactly
and the fact you've got that place yes
because it was hard work in the
beginning I spent a lot of time I mean
my social life went down I was spending
more time you know working my property
business than I had been on my normal
job my friends had no idea what on earth
I was doing they thought I was a crazy
person
but now I've got I've got all my time
back basically so we travel quite a bit
I'm able to kind of go away and be away
for weeks at a time and and everything
still runs without me because the great
thing about rental rents a guess is the
fact that and most mostly in property is
you do it once and you get paid ongoing
yeah it's all about cashflow passive
income which is which is really exciting
so what are your plans for the future
then besides the farm yeah that's pretty
much the big one
yeah because there's so many things I
mean 27 acres is pretty huge there's so
many different things we can do on there
so yeah we've got to put a tell puckers
now we've got a build up to 30 is the
goal and we've got bunnies and yeah we
do the glamping pot that's gonna be
awesome so that's my I do change
I do get bored quite easily so I might
be into something else in the year but
right now that's that's the big plan and
it is it's setting up that lifestyle
business for us was the goal so that's
the lifestyle work well congratulations
if I know you've been successful in what
you've done but if you were to speak to
your four years younger self who was
just finishing up with accountancy what
piece of advice one piece of advice
would you give them I would say focus so
when I first first got started before we
really decided on rent to rent I tried
to do every property strategy so I did a
training course one of those three-day
courses where you learn all the
strategies and I was like I'm a property
investor I'm gonna do all of them and I
spent six months running around like a
crazy person trying to do every strategy
and I got absolutely nowhere and it
wasn't until I said all right what are
my goals what am i focusing on that that
I was able to kind of build up that
momentum and get a proper business going
right yeah great advice fantastic and
today you've been with my certified palm
how was that oh that was excellent it's
a really good group of people so we
covered a good in-depth session on rent
to rent they asked loads of really
really good questions and I think they
went away with a lot of information to
actually get out there and start getting
the rent to rent good implementation
yeah as you probably right so I saw that
because they mean loads of them have
done loads of deals and they're getting
lots of sourcing and yeah yeah yeah and
and now we're off to the property
investor circle which is really good to
be excited so thanks thanks so much for
coming on the show and how would we
contact you I mean I would say whoever's
watching this you need to get Jackie's
book so if you just search what's the
name of the book rent search renter rent
on Amazon and my books will come up I've
got two of them right and how would
anyone get in touch with you if they
want to you know email you or give you a
chat with the self the best place to
find me is probably rent to rent Academy
code UK is my main rent to rent website
and that's got kind of contact form and
it's got loads of loads and loads of
information on rent to rent on there so
that's the best place to go so rent to
rent Academy code at UK excellent
regiment Academy Cody UK check out
Jackie Edwards thanks so much for coming
on the show thank you so much yes
exactly
thanks